tonight in the trial of Oscar Pistorius
his defense witness faces ridicule for
expected wearing the scientist on the
spot in court difficult question to
answer my lady
I'm going to be rude because you don't
listen that the question was is he an
expert
mr. nel yes please restrain yourself
good evening from Pretoria where Oscar
Pistorius has resumed his role as an
onlooker in court today as his legal
team continued to call other witnesses
in his defense that's meant that the
forensic geologist Roger Dixon has
continued his testimony about the
bullets fired that night from the
similarity of sounds of a cricket pad
hitting the toilet door and of a gun
firing Pistorius of course doesn't deny
firing the fatal shots which killed
reeva Steenkamp but he maintains it was
a tragic accident state prosecutor Harry
knell has kept up his aggressive
cross-examination really questioning
whether mr. Dickson was any kind of
expert at all Lisa Holland's been
watching mr. Dixon's uncomfortable day
in the witness box
Oscar Pistorius spent more than a week
on the stand denying he murdered his
girlfriend now his lawyer Barry Roux is
calling defense witnesses to back up the
athletes version of events the
prosecution claims 29 year-old reeva
Steenkamp was killed after the couple
had an argument on Valentine's Day last
year forensic expert
Roger Dixon said he believed Miss
Steenkamp had been shot in quick
succession and had been standing at an
angle behind the toilet door his
testimony challenges the state's version
that Miss Steenkamp would have had time
to scream after the first bullet the
body was closest to the door with the
hip wound consistent with bullet hole a
approximately the same distance from the
door when the arm was hit and then
falling backwards would explain why
there is no splinters in the hand or the
head as the deceased was falling for
shots in rapid succession and they hit
as she was falling and turning and by
the time the head had reached the height
approximately I would say about 89 he
hit at 89 centimeters on the wall
approximately that height the bullet
wound to the head 4.1 would be inflicted
and that is happening as the person is
hitting a magazine rack and ending up on
the floor head going forward resting
against the toilet bowl after an hour of
defense questioning mr. Dixon spent the
rest of the day under intense
cross-examination from the prosecutor
Harry knell who attempted to demolish
his credibility and his analysis you
qualified as a geologist
tomorrow's my first degree was in
chemistry and geology and jollity um you
obtained a master's in geology yes I did
my lady and currently we're you employed
currently at present I'm employed at the
University of Pretoria and the
department of geology I see that you
currently not affiliated to any forensic
body that is so hairy now then began to
inspect the witnesses expert credentials
you gave evidence on sound are you a
sound expert to that question I would
hope that my X my evidence that I
present is sound yes your analysis of
visibility and the dog did that require
in expert skill milady the instruments I
used there were my eyes it's what is
visible I'm not measuring light levels
whose to translate the light level so
many lovers into what you can see
depends on so many things and of course
I am NOT an expert in the exact precise
measurement of light levels I did not
use a machine your visibility in the
dark test you just used your own eyes I
used my eyes milady
are you a black better expert and I have
received no training in blood spatter
analysis milady what I've testified on
now was games that information was
gained as a result of the reports by
other expert witnesses who are
specialists in their area and putting
together that plus my own investigation
of the door looking at bullet fragments
looking at all the photographs that were
prior disposal and the scene what I did
is i reconstructed illogical for myself
based on my knowledge and experience a
logical sequence of events the witness
appeared to become confused as Harry now
doggedly dissected his evidence
difficult question to answer my lady
because I cannot remember specific
differences I do remember however that
as the case progressed and more
information looking at photographs diff
interpretations might have changed we
did change in my case but I cannot
mention specific differences the defense
lawyer Barry Roux had earlier played the
court a series of sound tests to show a
gun firing compared to a cricket bat
used by Oscar Pistorius to break the
toilet door down to get to reeva
Steenkamp after he had shot her the
defense claims witnesses are confusing
the sounds and therefore the sequence of
events first the cricket bat hitting a
door at a distance of 60 meters
then at a hundred and eighty meters it
was also tasting with the firing firing
this is 60 meters and at 180 meters
without a coat is the taste that you
attended my lady the first ones were the
cricket bat at 60 and 180 and their
second ones were the gun shots at 60 and
80 years the sound tests provoked fierce
cross-examination by mr. nel we just
wanted a recording so you you felt it's
as far as a scientific expert is
concerned that's enough if we can play a
sound club and I hit the bed that's
enough
is it do you think that's enough yes my
lady for the purposes of that test I
consider that to be enough mr. Dickson
then admitted he hadn't in fact been
present when all the gunshot tests were
conducted who's the Dickson really take
it from me I'm testing your integrity
you can take it the gunshots we heard
could not have happened on the night
that you were on a shooting range with a
bat because we have rapid shots and that
did not happen on that night am i right
and you are right my lady
there was no design and intent to
mislead the court or the prosecution or
the defense as to the nature of what we
have done then back to mr. Dixon's
expertise you're not a expert on wound
ballistics are you no my lady I am NOT
an expert on wound ballistics the
relentless blows drew a reprimand from
the judge the it's
a sister port please my lady I went on
the internet to listen to some bytes
that are used by people when they dub
them into movies and so there are
libraries on the Internet of different
sounds wood breaking that's hitting this
debt and the other thing I asked you a
different question I've stopped yeah you
know I'm going to be rude because you
don't listen the question was is he an
expert mister Nell yes milady please
just strain yourself
then mr. Dixon revealed he had only
closely photographed the toilet door
centerpiece of the forensic evidence
last month more than a year after reeva
Steenkamp death I had seen the mark on
the door I'd seen photographs taken on
the day of the event by the police of
the mark on the door however when I saw
it in the port with the lighting and it
was highly visible I thought yes that is
nice I was did not have the opportunity
with good lighting and a good camera to
take it beforehand and you exclude that
that could be father's of a Martin cloth
used in cleaning this though
my lady I did not observe the cleaners
putting an excessive amount of energy
into cleaning the door because that is
caused by a strong blow so I stay by my
conclusion that those fibers were caused
by the sock that was worn on the
prosthesis and not by a cleaner with a
modern cloth a few minutes we're going
to be discussing the defense strategy as
the Pistorius trial enters its final
phase first Roger Dixon finished his
evidence today giving his opinion on the
wounds that reeva Steenkamp suffered
your view of the blue marks on the
butter you were at the postmortem
what did you rely where that Marcus
described I looked at the description
made by Professor Simon in his post
mortem report the medial aspect of the
right Batak displays an irregular area
of contusion and blue discoloration of
the skin over an area measuring
approximately 40 by 30 millimeters with
indistinct lateral extension there are
external palpation does not reveal the
obvious presence of underlying
subcutaneous foreign objects and based
on that you said that it must be it
could be a bruise and she fell against
the magazine rack based on the
photograph Plus this information plus my
reconstruction of events magazine rack
that is how I interpreted yes milady
did you take anything else into account
of that about it and I'm not aware that
there was much else available about that
you'll be surprised
keep paging in that document I just want
to put on record you sit what am i right
I want to put that on record you open
the document you said what am i right
you open that document you looked at
better obviously what but let us read it
deep the section of the right gluteal
region following a posterior approach
reveals irregular wound tracks but
yielding only small irregular shrapnel
metal fragments confirmed by
transillumination extensive deep and
posterior hematoma formation is present
very describes it you missed it you mr.
Dixon just made an inference without
even reading the document that you
referred to they described what caused
that either sick to that whole area but
you are strong enough to tell the court
you know better in my layman's
understanding if the bullet had broken
up into many little pieces and there was
extensive hematoma and so on and it had
come to the surface it would have
discolored a large area rather than
being two lines that intersect
you see mr. Dixon now you call yourself
a layman you gave the evidence you were
strong about that you see how it
responsibilities to make inferences in
areas will not expect it's irresponsible
Amarante my lady I was interpreting the
marks that I saw and you interpreted to
fit your case I have a scenario which I
was recreating is he the most
irresponsible thing is if you refer to a
document and he don't even read the full
document well why would he come to court
to the High Court
give this evidence and you don't even
read the full document why would you do
that mr. Dixon
after a week of oscar pistorius in the
witness-box it was the turn of more
defense witnesses today and to discuss
the latest day in court I'm joined by
Alex Crawford our correspondent Lopez
does nevins who's a law enforcement
expert well in canvas of course who's
been giving us legal analysis all the
way through this and Alex just give us
an idea of what today was like in court
it was certainly a lot quieter after the
last week well it didn't have the great
drama that we've seen when Oscar
Pistorius was giving his evidence this
was much more technical it was much more
finite she was going through various
details but it was a bit like watching
someone having their fingernails pulled
out one by one as the prosecutor laid
into the defense witness and basically
tore his credibility his credentials
questioned his integrity and said at one
stage you don't appear to be an expert
in any of these fields which you've
testified in and that is the danger of
pretending you're an expert basically
was what he was saying it was not a
pretty sight Lobo you've been an expert
you've given evidence in court as the
policeman and as a lay expert so what
does it take to be an expert and what
are the dangers if you're not quite
expert well expert really is what the
word means is knowing more than other
people knowledgeable in that field and
the danger is sometimes it's hard to
admit that you don't know something and
I think the the the one element of a
good expert is to know when to and when
not to testify in court when to say no
to a case when you look at the evidence
and you see it doesn't really fit what
the client if you private expert what
the clients version is then you just say
listen I can't do this but to go in
front of an open court and purport to be
an expert in a field we are clearly not
is very very dangerous opinion evidence
is admissible in court but remember it's
still opinion the ultimate discretion is
still with the court to decide which
evidence to allow and to assimilate and
so on well then what's the point of it
today and what were the pluses and
minuses of the defense
putting mr. Dixon in court today if we
look at the weight of the evidence to be
attached to the evidence of Roger Dixon
obviously because his credibility he's
basically out of the door and let's call
a spade a spade
he did not stood up to the
cross-examination I don't think the
court is going to allow much weight to
be attached to his evidence so we are
back to square one from the perspective
of the defense they still only have
Oscar Pistorius version before court
which we know by now also was not that
satisfactory all in all and that's why
we said how crucial is he in this case
the actual the finer points of
ballistics after all we have at the
center of the case a man who admits
firing four shots and somebody died as a
result
well the sequence of the shots are
important and the reason for this is
that it is commonly known that with pain
people make a noise and the first round
hit the deceased in the hip which would
have caused an immense amount of pain
you've been hit yourself so you know yes
and it is it depends where the bullet
strikes it can be very painful and it's
very hard keeping quiet when you are in
such pain now when weapon is fired even
in the confined space and when you have
that ringing noise in the ears you can
still hear it doesn't make you totally
deaf you can still hear people speak to
you even on the shooting range if you
forget to put your ear protection on you
can still hear people speak to you so
there's a question over what did Oscar
Pistorius hear after the first round was
fired and what may be fired the other
three after the first round was fired
you remember the initial defense put up
there by Oscar Pistorius is one of
self-defense pitted of self-defense and
in order to be successful in that
defense you must prove that there was an
imminent danger and that you only
continued for as long as that danger was
facing in confronting you now suggesting
that he
year reeva Steenkamp shouting or
screaming after the first shot as
indicated I mean then he should have
stopped tests were being carried out on
a door which had in the meantime being
cleaned when it was in court and
sausages raised some questions I mean
several things I struck me was that how
much of the gathering of evidence or
research was being done so late in the
day by the defense was started yes
apparently Roger Dixon came in after the
trial started to take pictures of the
door to try and match the marks or
further match the marks of the bat
against the door and as the prosecutor
pointed out in between time since it's
been erected in this court the cleaners
have been wiping it saddling around with
it you know and it couldn't possibly be
still considered an exhibit the other
point that was raised was that the
gunshot tests were only done last week a
further set of gunshot tests were only
done last week when he think that this
trial has taken more than a year to come
to court that seems incredible Roger
Dixon tried to explain it away by saying
that well they'd got further evidence
and the they're sort of putting together
if the evidence was evolved which
actually played into the prosecutors
hands that they were trying to fit
together a certain story
what should the defense be trying to do
now what would the strategy be from
cases you've studied in the past they
will continue trying to cast a shadow
over the evidence given by the state and
they will try and attack every aspect of
evidence presented by the state and even
if they just succeed on one point it may
cast a shadow over just about anything
else so it is not so much as trying to
prove a ballistic point or a scientific
point or not it's just creating the
atmosphere that what the state presented
wasn't a hundred percent good it is
questionable they just need to cast a
shadow they don't have to prove
innocence the ultimate onus of proof is
on the state to prove beyond reasonable
doubt all that is expected from the
defense is put up a defense lay
foundation a foundation for it and then
follow that up with some kind of a
collaboration to a certain extent we're
looking for doubt if there's doubt in
the mind of the presiding bench and the
judge and the Assessors Oscar Pistorius
skip the benefit of the doubt regardless
whether the bench
from a personal perspective think or
concur with the ultimate result or not
Dave we've got a lawyer we've got a
legal trained expert sitting on the
bench that must pronounce judgment yet
and she might be inclined to say I do
believe the prosecution but still
there's doubt in my mind on this in this
basis and therefore I must give him the
benefit of the doubt in terms of our
Constitution and principles in our
Criminal Procedure the story goes on
Alex Lobert thank you very much
fascinating insight into the case so far
and maybe what lies ahead for us what
lies ahead for us is that we should be
back bright and early tomorrow morning
8:30 BST when the court opens again in
the Oscar Pistorius murder trial